consacré peau merci nous accordé cette
entrevue le plaisir la dernière fois qu
on s'était parlé c'était il y avait des
centaines de migrants qui mouraient en
mer en essayant d'atteindre les côtes de
l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est la route des balkans
qui retient l'attention
on a l'impression que ça s'accélère
cette crise cet afflux de migrants
je pense que les politiciens européens
et les populations européennes n'ont pas
encore là pris la mesure du phénomène
ces migrants viennent ces migrants vont
venir
quel que soit ce qu'en pensent les
européens donc si les gens viennent si
c'est un constat de fait et bien il faut
que les européens se disent alors soit
nous laissons faire ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est à dire que les
passeurs contrôle tout et nous on n'a
aucune idée qui vient et pourquoi et on
se retrouve avec des gens dont on ne
sait pas comment les organiser soit les
européens prennent le contrôle du
mouvement
et là il ya toute une série de choses à
faire par exemple pour les cyrières et
les erythréens
au lieu d'attendre que ces gens là
payent beaucoup d'argent et risquent
leur vie et qui arrive sur les rivages
de l'europe sans qu'on sache vraiment
pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'organise pas
pour ses séries s et erythréens ce qu'on
a fait pour les indochinois ya 40 ans on
va sélectionner des centaines de
milliers de personnes moi je pense qu'il
faudrait c'est là qu'il faudrait
probablement rétablir entre 1 à 2
millions de syriens et d'erythréens sur
les cinq prochaines années ce qui sont
des chiffres tout à fait gérable pour
l'ensemble du nord globale ça fait
quatre cent mille personnes par année
divisé en 32 pays représentant 850
millions d'habitants c'est parfaitement
gérable pour le canada ça signifierait à
peu près dix huit mille personnes par
année
une goutte d'eau dans ce qu'on reçoit
annuellement et pour les pays européens
ce serait gérable aussi est-ce que ça
serait vraiment gérable quand on voit
les réactions par exemple en allemagne
en ce moment où on brûle des centres
pour réfugiés où on voit toute cette
réaction et xénophobe parce que ces pays
là peuvent vraiment accueillir tous et
tous s'y réfugier alors peuvent au plan
économique
oui certainement au plan sociologique
absolument ces gens là pourrait être si
c'est bien organisé
ces gens là serait distribué dans toute
une série de vie
dans le pays et s'il ya un accord
politique européen sur cette conception
de l'accueil eh bien chacun des pays
irait recruter des mii des réfugiés dans
les pays de transit et chacun des pays
aurait son quota et ferait son travail
pour aller recruter des gens et
étalerait les arrivées de façon bien
organisée avec des billets d'avion et y
aurait par exemple pour l'allemagne pour
y avoir mis l'arrivée par semaine qui
serait dirigé vers divers villes sur
cinq ans tout ça est organisée tout ça
est mise en oeuvre on organisa avec les
pays de transit
on organise ça avec les ong dans le pays
d'accueil les gens sont intégrés
socialement reçoivent des cours de
langue
les enfants vont à l'école et en moins
d'1 ou 2 ans ces gens là sont sur le
marché du travail commence à payer des
impôts et en faisant ça on réduit la
panique de la population d'accueil
puisque c'est organiser ce n'est pas les
images de chaos que l'on voit à calais
ou que l'on voit sur les plages grecque
ou italienne
mais là on assiste tout à fait le
contraire de ce que vous dites
parce que là ça a l'air simple comme ça
et ça al'air humain est une bonne
solution mais en ce moment on construit
le mur entre les murs de barbelés entre
les pays pour empêcher ces gens là donc
d'entrée vous vous sentez comment quand
vous voyez ces images quand vous voyez
ce qui se passe sur place
ça rappelle d'autres époques
malheureusement le problème que nous
avons c'est que les politiciens des
partis centristes de droite comme de
gauche sont incapables d'avoir un
discours politique positif sur la
migration de montrer les bienfaits de la
migration comment la configuration
contribuer à l'économie contribuent à la
diversité économique contribue à créer
des liens avec des pays étrangers qui
crée des liens commerciaux et culturels
les pays de l'est blé les formations
politiques du centre sont incapables de
le faire parce que le discours politique
sur la migration est dominée par les
partis d'extrême droite
les marine le pen mais nigel farage de
ce monde dont c'est le seul atout
électoral
il faut se rendre compte que le problème
est un problème électoral les migrants
ne votent pas 9 heures ils n'ont aucune
voie politique sur la scène électorale
si vous ne votez pas vos droits sont en
danger
les femmes ont connu ça avant d'avoir le
droit de vote on peut penser que des
pays comme l'australie les états unis le
canada ont une plus grande capacité
d'accueil les états unis vient de dire
on va prendre cinq à huit mille réfugiés
syriens le canada avait promis d'en
prendre
13000 il y en a à peine un millier qui
sont arrivés ici
ouais est ce qu'on doit faire plus c'est
ce que le canada peut faire plus un pays
comme le canada pour avoir un rôle de
leadership on a on a historiquement
accueilli 5000 kosovar par exemple au
moment du kosovo on a accueilli 40
millogo hongrois lors de la crise de 56
c'était 20 % de tous les réfugiés en moi
on avait fait on a fait des efforts le
canada historiquement lorsque des crises
se présentait là nous sommes absents de
la scène politique internationale
complètement et nous pourrions nous
pourrions annoncer que nous allons
prendre 25 mille trente mille réfugiés
syriens par année pour les cinq six
prochaines années
on pourrait faire ça dans l'ensemble de
l'émigration qu'on reçoit annuellement
ça ne représenterait pas une grosse
augmentation pourrait très bien faire ça
et nous ne le faisons pas c'est le
contraire en fait le gouvernement a
impulsé à serrer la vis sur les
immigrants clandestins de fun mais si on
y réfléchit
mais là moi je moi j'espérais de la part
du canada et de l'ensemble des pays nos
globes est un geste positif de politique
de réétablissement fait en collaboration
avec le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
des nations unies qui avec qui on
établirait des priorités avec qui on
organiserait l'ensemble de la machinerie
nécessaire qu'au canada on est habitué à
faire ici on ne sait rien comme c'est le
cas en ce moment
qu'est ce qui peut arriver mais ce qui
va arriver c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est à dire que ça continue ça
ne s'arrête pas il ya cette année on a
on est à trois cent mille maintenant on
va peut-être se rendre à 350 milles
cette année c'était 200 milles l'été
dernier
ce sera un os 300 400 milles l'été
prochain et ça va continuer probablement
pendant tout l'hiver également parce que
par la grèce
le passage est facile même en hiver
on risque d'avoir exactement la même
situation il ya il ya 4 millions de
syriens qui sont bloqués dans trois pays
du moyen-orient voisins de l'europe et
dans lequel il n'ya dans lesquelles il
n'y a aucune perspective d'intégration
si nous facilitions l'entrée de façon
réglementé organisées en fonction de
priorités que nous choisissons et bien
le marché pour les pacers disparaît
alors pour l'instant ce sont des images
de chaos
si on ne fait rien ce chaos va continuer
si nous décidons collectivement
d'organiser ce passage est bien on peut
en faire quelque chose de tout à fait
positifs pour l'europe pour le nord
globale et pour le monde
merci mme coup franc 60e plaisir